[Music]
let's go to sierra in seattle washington
what's up sierra
hey dr john
how are we doing i i'm doing great how
are you i am rocking onto the break of
dawn what's going on how can i help
oh man life goals just failed okay
listen with all due respect you've got
to set higher goals for yourself it's
awesome all right so what's up uh no no
achieve your dreams before age 30 and
then
yes but you do okay all right you want
to shoot for the moon not for like a
medium-sized volkswagen right not for a
small car but anyway okay so what's up
how can i help hey man
all right so
um i
i have a difficult relationship with my
in-laws in particular my mother-in-law
and i know i'm totally unique
in that struggle i've never heard this
call okay so
well so
a bunch of things
uh mostly we have very um
it's very strange to specialize as my
husband i move to the other side of the
state okay so um there's a lot of
mismatch expectations
um i see in my mother-in-law that she's
not
she doesn't respect a lot of my
boundaries a lot of my expectations for
how like
i would like to be treated and we've
been working on it for like five years
and it's one of those things where every
time it starts to feel like we're making
some progress we can step back right
back to the very square
beginning again and she'll call my
husband up and say things like i don't
know if we can
all meet up as a family you know can can
just you and the kids come visit not
like can you leave sierra at home what's
your husband say to that nonsense
no way mom that's my wife good for him
you married well
i did i did she raised a good boy
despite her nonsense
um so what what do you do that's so
terrible
fix it sierra what's wrong i'm just
kidding like what happened
well so um i mean first of all we moved
away um we had an opportunity to you
know for my husband to pursue a career
he wanted to be in and for us to move to
a much lower cost of living area and so
we did and that means we took the only
grandkids in the family with us and um
and you recognize that one of these
that she can't be mad at her darling
little boy and so she's got to take
swings at
the next adult in line which is you
right
yep there you go exactly
so you recognize you don't deserve that
crap too right
oh yeah no i mean we made we made the
best decision we could and frankly
looking at both sides of our families
they made that decision at one point too
and um so one of the things that really
you know has broken my heart about this
whole struggle and the fact that this
relationship has been so difficult is
i was so excited to have
two
intact sets of grandparents nearby for
my kids
because both my husband and i lived in
places where it just wasn't possible for
our grandparents to be around a ton
and so i was really really excited about
that and then we had this opportunity to
move and my family's close
but his is not they're about four hours
away so they're not like
you know it's not east coast west coast
but it's it's a waze right and so it
makes visits puts a lot of burden on
visits to be super fun and super
action-packed and super busy and one of
the one of the big sticking points has
been things like because we moved away
my in-laws feel like it's our obligation
to come to them hey
sierra
you're not crazy
thank you and your in-laws are immature
and they're jerks
and your kids deserve better than that
your husband deserves better than that
and you deserve better than that
and in your head and in your heart
it's never gonna add up
because you got two people that it makes
no sense that they don't act like adults
now adults would be heartbroken that
their only grandkids moved away of
course they would and they would miss
you like crazy of course they would
i'm from texas four hours is your
next-door neighbor right that's not a
long time
that's a weekend
that's a we're coming to hang out and
we're just gonna head home right it's
not temper tantrum and that if you don't
see us then i guess it cause here's
what's gonna happen your kids are gonna
make extraordinary
wonderful intimate relationships with
your parents
and they are going to be right or die
with your parents and it's going to be
awesome
one because your parents are close two
because your parents aren't acting like
children
and they already are it's
it's awesome so special here's who's
missing out
on how many kids do you have
we have a three-year-old one-year-old
and we're another on the way yeah
awesome
here's who the big loser here is
your your husband's parents
they're the losers you know why because
they're not gonna get to meet and love
and be intimately close to three
wonderful little kids
they're gonna take their grown-up temper
tantrums and miss out on the life of
three extraordinary little kids
they're gonna miss out on their son who
they raised who's a great guy who's
gonna be a great dad who's a great
husband
they're gonna miss out on all of that
because they're throwing grown-up temper
tantrums
and you can't do anything about it
and so the hardest thing you're gonna
have to do
is mourn the fantasy of the four living
grandparents that were gonna be so
great because you got two
and anytime
anytime
a set of parents calls outside of some
abuse issues some major addiction issues
some major violation stuff
and would ever say something like
hey can you and the kids just come but
don't bring her
good for him for saying absolutely not
that's my wife
and that is the clear signal to you guys
it's time for y'all to move on
and that means you're gonna have to make
your own thanksgiving plans and your own
christmas plans and that means that you
can say things like we're having
thanksgiving dinner with our friends
here and it's going to be
thursday
at 4 p.m you're welcome to join us
and that's it
and they get to make grown-up choices
about whether they want to be in your
life and in your kid's life or not
because you guys are gonna do
thanksgiving with or without them
does that make sense
yeah
and it's hard for a second
and then once you draw that boundary and
you hold it up for the first time and
it's going to come at a big moment right
it's going to come at some big dramatic
oh you mean you're not coming to the our
whatever halloween event
nope we're doing trick-or-treating here
you're welcome to join us that night um
we're gonna have three kids under the
age of four so we're not gonna have
y'all gonna need to get a hotel but we'd
love to have you here it'd be great
and um here's the event that we're gonna
be at and if they choose to join you
awesome awesome and if they don't they
made a grown-up choice and it's okay to
be sad
but you can't own it and you gotta it's
so trite and so silly you guys gotta set
it down
and that starts really with just
mourning it
is your husband's heart broken by all
this
is he surprised or he sometimes this is
a big surprise when grandkids are
involved often though
like dude i grew up with these parents
because they've been acting like this
for years
yeah it was it's been an evolving thing
like when we were first married it's not
that my husband
couldn't see what was wrong but
you know he'd been in the soup for so
long and he couldn't see quite why it
was what it was affecting me so much
so it's taken him a little while but
it's one of those things that like once
you see it you can't unsee it and so
he's he's ride or die with me for sure
and he's like you're my my future and
the mother of my babies and all of that
and so
he's like mom the idea of me coming for
a visit with just the kids and not my
wife is asinine i'm not doing that so
here's what we're done with here's what
we're done with we're done with long
dramatic phone calls
and we're done with
we're done with long dramatic text
exchanges
we're going to move into a season of
boundaries which is going to be
information transmission okay doesn't
mean you don't love them it means you're
wasting everybody's time by having these
long
finally we're here and you hang up and
you're like finally
this adult is gonna act like an adult
they're not five years five years of
this
okay
so
yeah um
what would be really awesome is to send
out here in the next 30 days you and
your husband sit down and plan it out
send out
holiday plans 2021.
here's what we're doing and send it in
an email
that's very concise we will be spending
christmas with my family on these days
uh we will both be at work so we're not
gonna be able to hang out
um we will have this weekend off if
you'd like to come visit us that would
be wonderful
due to uh you don't have to give a due
to we will not be traveling this year
um and we will be doing thanksgiving at
our house and we do plan to have some
friends over and some neighbors and some
community members over we'd love to have
you too you're invited
that is it
and any dramatic email response and he
calls your husband is like can you
believe it
that's their choice
that's the that is the choice they're
making
right and this is gonna be hard on your
husband this is like making me sad
thinking about this because i always
want to honor my parents i always want
to honor the adults in my life that's
the right thing to do
and it's hard when ultimately i have to
make boundaries
and i do unfortunately i won the lottery
with my in-laws i won the lottery so but
what i'm saying like
even the even in our relationships
though
boundary i mean clarity and boundaries
are super important that way it just
doesn't turn into this weird everybody's
on the same page that makes sense so
everybody's going to win by doing this
anyway and you can send this email to
your parents too we'd love to have you
here at this time it's going to be so
great and then you're going to find in
your home with you and your husband and
three rambunctious bananas kids running
around one of them's not going to be
running around one of them's going to be
yeah not running around oh i can't
believe you have three out of four it's
gonna be awesome um oh it's gonna be so
exciting well so that's actually
something i i wanted to ask you about
okay go quick we're up against the clock
go quick what do you got sure sure so we
had we just had a visit and i know
they're going to be off my back for a
bit but the holidays are coming and then
right after the holidays
and so i'm trying to figure out and get
my head around what do i say about
meeting the new baby
whatever you want it's your baby it's
your house
it could be my mom's coming to stay with
us for three weeks to take care of the
two little ones
while i either you gotta go back to work
your husband's work whatever
and we will be accepting visitors at our
house on the beginning
fill in the blank
that's it
it doesn't have to be dramatic it
doesn't and obviously you're not going
to be punitive and be ugly and rude and
disrespectful
or it might be they can swing by they're
not going to be able to stay at your
house because your mom's going to be
staying there or nobody's going to be
staying there you're welcome to come
um we're not going to have any visitors
staying with us but you're welcome to
come by and hold the baby and see the
baby and do all that kind of stuff
um you can take our little kids out to
dinner um while i'm recovering or
whatever you set the boundaries it can
be whatever you want and this could be a
really hard heartbreaking time
or it could be the you could do this
write this email with a smile on your
face
like oh my gosh i get this i this is my
baby and my house
we get to co-create imagine that yeah we
need to decide we need to decide it's up
to us it's our house right
what a cool season what a cool yeah
uh whenever our second child was born my
wife gave me a list
like for the hospital don't say this
these things don't ask these questions
and i was like
oh oh ok ok
it made the everything so great it made
everything so great she sent an email
out to my mom to her mom it was
wonderful everybody was on the same page
right and there wasn't any of this weird
like do we do do we come in do we not
come in are we coming over it was just
clean as could be it was awesome right
you
you sierra get to choose
now don't fire this off without your
husband obviously sit down with him and
say here's what i'm thinking we're gonna
draw the boundaries is what it's gonna
look like and so you get to dream and
imagine
october november december
january you get to just make the rules
here
so great so cool
respectfully and with dignity
your life your boundaries
go from there
hopefully
hopefully
your in-laws will stand up and say
wow this is incredible good for them
good for them we're going to honor this
family this new young family we're going
to honor them we're going to love them
they've made some great grown-up
decisions we miss those grandkids so bad
we miss our son we kind of miss her but
not really and
we're going to honor what they're saying
or they're going to throw temper tantrum
but for five years you guys have tried
the same thing you've got to do
something different this is about
boundaries this is about respect this is
about dignity this is about y'all making
grown-up choices and them making
grown-up choices
they're big boys and girls and they did
what they did
so did y'all
proud of you for doing what's right for
your family now you're gonna go into a
new season you're gonna mourn the end of
this fantasy of these magical four
grandparents
and you can deal with the reality
of
two pretty cool grandparents and two who
sometimes act like children
heartbreaking heartbreaking
heartbreaking but that's where we're at
that's reality let's
let's go
let's deal with that story and go from
there thank you so much for your call
sierra thank you so so so much uh i know
i was joking at the beginning you're not
the only one everybody deals with this
everybody does with this so thank you so
much for being vulnerable and telling
your story